In this video, we're
going to look at scales.
This first plot shows
the average height
of a 21-year-old
male in centimeters.
The x-axis is time, starting
in 1871, and ending in 1975.
Each person
represents the height,
at a different point in time,
and the points are evenly
spaced in time, so
the x-axis is OK.
The y-axis ranges from just
under 160 to 180 centimeters,
which isn't inherently bad,
but does overstate the change.
The real problem is the bars.
If it was accurate,
we would only
really see the heads of
the men, but instead we
see their whole bodies, making
it seem as if people have not
only doubled in height, but
they've also double in width.
This next plot also
has issues with scale.
The total range of
the plot is 8% to 10%,
although all the numbers fall
in the range of 8.6% to 9.2%.
If we plotted the y-axis
on a 0% to 10% scale,
the conclusion would be
that nothing is really
changing at all.
The last point in the chart
is at the wrong height,
and the size of the markers
makes the relative locations
hard to distinguish.
Also notice that the gap between
9.0% and the 8.9% markers
on the far left side, and
the 8.9% and 8.8% markers,
have a different gap.
This plot shows the relative
breakdown of teachers
by race in a certain
teaching program.
The Caucasian bar is truncated,
which is a risky choice,
but could be appropriate
in some situations.
A much bigger problem is that
the scale of each blue bar
is entirely different.
For example, the Native
American bar is about a third
of the length of the
African American bar,
but there are more than 10
times as many African Americans
in this program as
Native Americans.
In fact, visually, this plot
is completely meaningless.
The only useful thing
about it is the numbers.
But even there, there
is a bit of confusion,
as Native Americans are
given to one decimal place,
but the others are rounded.
Which when combined with
the confusing scales,
casts doubt on the
correctness of the numbers.
Here is a before and
after of the same data.
On the left, we see
the US military expense
in the right axis, and troop
count on the left axis.
Both the line and bar
plots are individually OK,
but the combination
is misleading.
Because you have mixed two
units, dollars and people,
there is a false
impression of some sort
of crossover point in
1995 that does not exist.
On the right is the same data
presented in a different way.
We now have troops
on the x-axis,
and dollars on the y-axis.
The line moves through
time now, allowing
us to see when moments of change
occurred, such as decreases
in troop count, through the
90s, at the end of the Cold War,
the increase in
spending of the 2000s,
and the recent decreases
in military spending.
The final visualization
I want to show you today
is all about the different
types of household.
The US Census
Bureau periodically
determines how many households
are comprised, for example,
of married couples with
and without children,
people living alone, and so on.
First of all, I'm not saying
this is a bad visualization.
In fact, if we are interested
in the relative share
of each type of household
in a particular year,
it's actually pretty good.
However, if what
we're interested in
is the rates of change
across the years,
this is next to useless.
The key problem is that the
x-axis is completely off.
The gap between the first
two columns is 10 years,
but the gap between
the last two columns
is only 2 years, meaning
that the rates are
hard to read from this.
If we're not interested
in the rates of changes,
but just want to compare two
years at a time, it's not bad,
but it's not easy either.
Try comparing 1970
married without children
to 2010 married
without children,
without looking at the numbers.
Can you tell if it
has grown or shrunk?
Finally, and more
generally, this chart
shows relative numbers.
If you look at
absolute numbers, we
might find the total number of
couples married with children
is actually constant, but the
number of other households
has increased.
We are now going
to change into R
to try plotting this
data as a line chart.